Joshua was with us in Bend Oregon hi
Joshua how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up hey I'm
new to the process and I'll just give
you a quick rundown I'm on baby step two
I'm probably more gazelle intense and I
should be according to my life and my
question is around my house so my house
payment currently is around nineteen
hundred and seventy five dollars a month
my take-home salary
well my salary is atak a year and then I
have I can get up to a $36,000 year
bonus that's based monthly based on
performance historically trending I
usually hit pretty close to what I
thought that is so altogether 120 a year
my current instigated in my house is
four point nine nine if everything goes
as planned I'll be completely out of
debt
other than my house statement in March
this coming year good um so what we have
our house currently at sale it is
blessed with one of your yuppies but the
market has been was really really hot I
said I just stopped so 45 days no offers
on the table and now I'm just thinking
about it like if I want to buy a new
house invent average home price is four
hundred and forty thousand dollars my
house is worth about trim almost four
hundred right now I sell it I'll walk
with it around 100k why are you so in it
well that was the question
so we originally had thought we were
going to sell to eliminate some debt and
as I got going through this I just took
your advice and got as intense as
possible and cut here and cut there and
I'm getting rid of a car and I now don't
have to I can get us off and cash flow
everything and we don't absolutely love
the house but we absolutely don't hate
it either but to get another house in
bin and it's going to take a couple
hundred thousand dollars to get to that
twenty five percent you know my take on
pay that you suggest so you've been a
help in house if you sell your house and
you need a couple hundred thousand
dollars more you'd be moving up in house
the average home break has been right
now your houses in the band I know it is
that's not logical your he would have to
be moving up in house to a nicer house
even if we didn't want to move up even
if we wanted to say exactly the same I
would have to put the same amount of
money down and that thing would be
wrapped around what it is right now
25 percent to get to the 25 percent then
it's gonna be out of I just need to save
more money to put down so that's how I
would stay where you are
that's what I was thinking - yeah not
necessarily forever but for now right so
the follow-up says should I refinance
because right now my rates four point
nine nine percent and I thank you I can
get it - well if I go with a fifteen
Airfix I can get done like three point
eight three that takes my payment to
about twenty-five twenty-six hundred
dollars a month which I can swing but
it's above ability to do that I wouldn't
do that right now let's just say where
you are right now because that's a one
percent move is all and you know it's
gonna take you three years to break even
by the end of three years you may be
moving but for today you don't need to
move to get out of debt you don't need
to move because your house payments out
of line you don't need to move because
you hate your house because you don't
hate it you don't love it but you don't
hate it and so I think you just calm
down a little bit sit right where you
are let's get out of debt and then let's
reassess in eighteen months when you
want to talk about moving and if you're
planning to stay long-term at that point
and rates are still low i would look at
refinancing but for today i would just
sit tight on everything regarding your
house and just ride this out